uh one of the biggest producers in the
game is here welcome thank you bro thank
you yes sir how's up first of all man uh
I know uh you're one of the very few
artists who could say they have a
diamond single yep and I didn't even
realize drip too hard was Diamond like
Ace was like make sure you bring up the
fact he's got a diamond record and I was
like is drip too hard diamond damn sure
is that [__] is crazy yeah that's got to
feel crazy cuz that that's not there's
not that many people who could have that
on the resume these days bro that's like
Michael Jackson [__] you know that's 10
platinum records yeah if you don't know
yeah no yeah it do feel crazy I mean I
guess it's just a blessing bro like I
can't I can't call it anything else you
know what was your kind of like uh cuz I
I guess that's kind of the project that
we kind of like you became more like a
household name in hip-hop that tag of
yours kind of give me a little breakdown
on like your come up as a producer in
Atlanta cuz it is a very
very um flooded Marketplace for
producers these days and it's and it's
hard to break through it's hard to get
placements so kind of give me like a
rundown like how you started producing
and like just your come up well I I
started engineering so um engineering
was like I got fired from my job and
that became my job you know what I mean
and that's how I was hustling making
money but I always had the passion to be
a producer engineering was literally
just how I how I ate you know from day
to day but that's also how I met all the
artists and at that time Atlanta was a
place it still is but it was even more
of a place where we just embraced
everybody so if you was from Atlanta and
you knew you know such and such or you
went to high school such and such you
had an opportunity to get inside the
studio if you knew what you was doing so
I took so many of those opportunities
just friends and people that I grew up
with like you know I'll record you for
free I got beats for free uh [__] I'll
sit here all night for free you know
what I mean whatever it is and I just
slowly